die korona waren aber sie ist eine der
erfolgreichsten apps weltweit
die erfolgreichste app weltweit aber wie
gut läuft die korona waren app
inzwischen weil ich aus dem risikogebiet
wien zurückkehre mache ich den test
gleich am flughafen in berlin tegel
im testcenter für reiserückkehrer wie
schnell erhalte ich mein testergebnis
mit der app ich habe jetzt mein test
gemacht und habe ihr so einen qr code
bekommen sie von qr-codes soll ich in
der korona waren innerhalb von 72
stunden hätte ich dann mein ergebnis
dann geht's ab nach hause in quarantäne
aus der ich erst wieder raus darf wenn
es negative testergebnis vorliegt
test und apps sind mittels qr-code
schnell verbunden natürlich gibt es noch
kein ergebnis
technisch funktioniert die mitteilung
via app so das labor untersucht die
probe und teilt über den qr-code dem
verifikation server beim rk ihm ein
testergebnis mit
die app kann mit dem qr code ebenfalls
auf diesen server zugreifen und meldet
mir im besten falle das testergebnis zur
selben zeit wie das labor
soweit die theorie tag 4 in quarantäne
das testergebnis hätte mir eigentlich
innerhalb von 72 stunden übermittelt
werden sollen
aber die app meldet das testergebnis
lägen noch nicht vor
das klang beim start der korona waren
irgendwie anders
die korona waren app ist ein wichtiger
helfer wenn es darum geht
infektionsketten zu erkennen und zu
unterbrechen
sie ist ein wichtiges weiteres werkzeug
bei der eindämmung der pandemie bei der
eindämmung dieses virus weil dadurch ich
dieses testergebnis so schnell erfahren
im gesundheitsamt berlin-reinickendorf
merkt man davon wenig hier informieren
sie die patienten von testergebnis in
der regel zuerst per fax und telefon
der alte weg ist aber zuverlässig also
wenn im labor das positive ergebnis da
ist kriegen wir sozusagen minuten gleich
das ergebnis ins gesundheitsamt
geliefert zuverlässig derweil sitzen die
betroffenen patienten zu hause und
warten über wochen dass sie über ihre
app informiert werden
zugleich droht gesundheitsämtern in
vielen deutschen städten
angesichts der infektion der
kontrollverlust dabei sollte die app
auch sie entlasten doch dieser
potentiellen nutzen viel im datenschutz
zum opfer das ist ein wenn sie so wollen
ein doofes computerprogramm was ihnen
immer nur vorgegeben das zeug ausspuckt
aber was nie auf ihr eigentliches
individuelles problem eingehen kann
da sind wir besser die app ist im grunde
genommen eher lästig sie hilft uns in
der pandemie bekämpfung leider überhaupt
nicht runter erinnern
nein wegen nutzlosigkeit texten es
funktioniere die übermittlung per app
sehr sicher sagt patrick thema redakteur
bei heise online
neben der programmierung hat er sich
aber mal die nutzerzahlen genauer
angesehen
das ist ich habe mir noch mal die ganz
frischen zahlen anguckt an diesen beiden
und 900 download wir sind bei ich habe
16 millionen über mit der testergebnisse
davon waren ungefähr 12.000 positiv
rechnet man nach werden nur rund zehn
prozent aller tests mit der app
übermittelt
inzwischen erfahre ich mein corona test
aus berlin ist beim drk blutspendedienst
baden württemberg hessen gelandet mit
sitz in frankfurt am main
das labor soll an die korona waren app
angeschlossen sein
aber nutzt es die app für testergebnisse
die hotline des labors nicht erreichbar
der abruf auf der webseite klappt nicht
seit fast zehn tagen sitze ich nun in
quarantäne fest irgendwie habe ich das
gefühl mein corona ist es entweder
verloren gegangen oder es interessiert
sich niemand mehr das ergebnis
mitzuteilen
beim blutspendedienst heißt es man kenne
mich nicht zuordnen
als ich per mail nachfrage warum ich das
ergebnis nicht einfach per app erhalten
kann bekomme ich als antwort ich solle
den test wiederholen lassen später
antwortet das drk es könne seine
untersuchungsergebnisse gar nicht an die
korona waren app übermitteln
zitat dieses technisch nicht möglich war
niemals vorgesehen und wurde auch nicht
kommuniziert stattdessen nutzt der
drk-blutspendedienst für seine test
stellen seine eigene app warum wird so
ein labor mitten in der pandemie mit
test stellen in ganz deutschland
beauftragt ohne die korona war app zu
nutzen
allein in berlin betreibt das drk alle
corona station für reiserückkehrer an
flughafenbus und hauptbahnhof
[Musik]
wie groß ist der finanzielle aspekt in
der ganzen geschichte geht es um
technische probleme oder geht es ums
geld
also ich habe gehört das labor als skoda
muskeln gefühle das problem hatten wir
das mal zum arzt gegangen und da bleibt
natürlich unser ziel und das haben wir
bewusst folgen hat und auf der anderen
seite sollten sie hatten bei geld
investieren um halt die anwendung für
die app zu schaffen und da haben wir
gesagt nein das können wir nicht das
freundlich und genau deshalb platzte
telekom-chefs schon vor wochen der
kragen
15 labore sind nicht bereit sind nicht
bereit eine entsprechende
digitalisierung schnittstelle aufzubauen
es kam lapidar die antwort der aufwand
ist es für die ab zu hoch in einem labor
in lübeck dass testergebnisse pf
verschickt das der telekom-chef die
labore angreift findet man hier gar
nicht lustig das hat mich geärgert weil
es einfach nicht der wahrheit entspricht
die politik war vorweg marschierten
hatte gesagt die app wird jetzt
eingeführt aber dahinter war noch viel
niemandsland und das musste sehr schnell
geschlossen werden das haben die labor
gemacht und deshalb fand ich so ein
bisschen despektierlich zu sagen die
labore haben jetzt schuld was der
telekom-chef verschwieg und mit der app
zu arbeiten fallen softwarekosten an je
labor zwischen 10 und 25 tausend euro
bei den ganz kleinen laboren kann ich
mir das vorstellen dass es einfach ein
finanzielles problem ist wenn ich nur
wenige teste mache dann macht es für
mich kein ist es für mich nicht
interessant entsprechend zu investieren
aber auch für angeschlossene labore
lauern im prozess jede menge
fehlerquellen die eine übertragung der
tests verhindern
formulare ohne qr codes zum beispiel
oder schlicht gedruckte als die ersten
scheine erschienen waren die teilweise
von schlechter druckqualität so dass wir
dann nach arbeiten muss und man kann
sich vorstellen ist ein relativ großer
aufwand
außerdem muss jeder patient an der test
stelle ausdrücklich erklärt haben dass
er sein ergebnis per app haben will
an dieser stelle sollte das kreuz fehlt
es darf das ergebnis nicht an die korona
waren app übermittelt werden
dann ist die app leider nutzlos mann war
somit vielen anderen dingen beschäftigt
dass es einfach etwas zu kurz gekommen
ist wir wünschen uns deshalb dass man
das noch nachholt noch ist ja noch sehr
viel luft nach oben
viel luft nach oben bei immer weiter
steigenden infektionszahlen das drk
findet plötzlich doch noch meinen befund
negativ
das stand schon einen tag nach dem test
fest nur erfahren hätte ich das banani
und die korona waren app meldet es bis
heute nicht
[Musik]